this is very nice that buildings
beautiful oh this looks like my studio
I've come to MIT on about vacations and
I've been mostly fascinated by the
participants or the students I guess you
would call them these people are in a
situation where they have to find out
how to create the future little Sun is a
way of holding hands with the Sun the
project is about our ability to take
something which is incredibly abstract
like understanding energy and then make
it somehow tangible it has a solar panel
it has batteries on the inside to store
the energy and it has a small LED to
emit the energy is light there 1.6
billion people in the world without
access to electricity it's very much
about energy poverty
it's about lack of development
opportunity the work of art in my mind
is not necessarily this piece of plastic
it's much more the whole system of
working together with different entities
and people on the way to actually bring
it to finally rural users in a chain
which will ideally have a number of
local prophets in it on the way when we
discussed bringing little son to MIT it
was because I have strong confidence in
the sort of resonance between why and
how when people say something about how
they want to do something you can
sometimes in inside of that or
underneath that you can see why make it
simple simplicity is crucial the idea
should be like an elevator pitch
packing arts is a festival in hackathon
exploring the intersection of art
entertainment technology and
entrepreneurship the little son is
really such a perfect example of a type
of thing that we want to encourage here
with the hackathon you get a chance to
work on something change it see it in a
different way little sign is gonna be
really fun to hack on what we're
proposing is a community that's centered
around a website that's going to there's
a lot of components about the project
lives on which are very much about
social communities infrastructure the
ability to make choices for yourself
being independent saying I'm gonna take
the Sun and empower myself and I'm gonna
read tonight I'm gonna educate myself
what the infinite corridor
the infinite corridor did I make that no
that's their title for this space oh
yeah because it's a long Ricardo
my work has tried to in various ways
address this question of is reality
actually real by being really sedan
relative and is it a construction could
I change it can I change my world to
what I do have impact on my surroundings
can I feel that impact or is it just a
theoretical impact so all those
questions and if you think about it
little Sun is right in there in the
heart of all these questions what we're
doing with little Sun is we actually
making a real impact for people in rural
areas looking at the job with the pins
sticking out it brings awareness of the
collectivity of it
you need something in between theory and
action which of course could be called
MIT the opportunities are immense I mean
the power of MIT is far beyond the power
of any company that I know and so I see
that collaboration take form in many
many shapes electric circuits the
material expertise is it battery
expertise is it business expertise I do
think we need to start to treasure what
creativity is capable of now we're sort
of in an engineering environment I
really encourage and suggest that you
would reach out and ask creative people
and that might slow you down it might
take you on a detour but generally
speaking I really think it's worth it
creativity is the success of the
consequences that a choice has so I
choose between red or blue but that is
not a creative choice the creativity in
the choice between red and blue is the
impact that this charge has on the world
and you really only make these creative
choices once you are inspired see now I
would say that is a skill that one can
nurture I think the first idea has a lot
of potential in for instance off-grid in
building community
a great amount of the success of MIT has
been its ability to to lean out into
other fields and I would encourage this
to continue into the arts into the
dancers into the writers and theaters
and ballets and music and so on this is
I think one of the solutions in which we
can create a lot of chains
you
you